oh yes the bean 3/5 Bryson being like
super clean this another step they got
they got a little vacation yeah it was
pretty awesome that's awesome
went to Europe man yeah oh she was
practicing that I went to Poland and I'm
with the Ukraine then we came back
beautiful moon
well we got a great guest to kick it off
you said we got the number one
heavyweight kickboxer in the world here
no champion dude what's up my brother
Laurie good how are you guys thanks
we're great man yeah it's great to have
you in here look at this belt [ __ ]
awesome down to the last time I saw you
man yeah yeah you look good thank you
look good brother you're six six
she's 565 yeah how much you weigh 260
120 kilos so how much is that
oh it's 2.2 kilos per pound right so I
think it's about to 270 [ __ ] monster
bro yeah let me see exactly 120 120
kilos times two point no that's wrong
120 times two point two no that didn't
work yeah man
to 264 solid reco 30 wait so your front
let's start let's bring it back yeah so
you're from the Netherlands yes sir
we're at uh
no it's about where you come from so I
come from from a small town
it's called Halsted er and it's about 30
minutes from Rotterdam that probably
everybody knows and I think an hour 20
hour 20 minutes from Amsterdam okay so
it's a little bit on the in the south
it's quiet and I grew up there so
everybody knows me and that's what yeah
that's what I like because in Holland
it's like crazy now from the the
popularity of kickboxing so everywhere I
go big cities to people pictures and
it's yeah it's a it's sometimes it's
hard especially when you were with the
family of course yeah but yeah we work
with it but over there where I live
everybody knows me into just let me be
that's correct yeah that's great you
know bas Rutten yeah of course yeah
that's your I'm sure you grew up like
watching yes for sure he's a hometown
hero yeah yes home country hero yeah
love boss yeah great yeah he's a great
guy so much energy over 'into uh so
that's a yeah we trained once or twice
were you always a big kid yep yeah
always the biggest guy yeah always the
biggest guy in the class for me too
yeah ever since I was a little kid I was
always the biggest kid I remember my
quads
doing my first demonstration kickboxing
fight I was seven I started when I was
six Wow but my dad was teaching so he
said I want to give some more I'm gonna
get some more people to the gym so let's
do let's do a demonstration day so
everybody does something okay cool
you're gonna do demonstration fight so
cool so our seven and I was fighting a
guy was 10 and it was fun it was fun
it's actually on YouTube it's yeah it's
crazy really yeah and when I when I
watch it now I was like dad what were
you thinking
he just had us put on gloves but we were
a kickboxer we were also kicking we had
no shin guards so I was like back in the
demonstration just a demonstration but I
remember after that fight jumping on my
mother's lap crying so I'm not doing
that anymore by the way
but yeah that's that's how it all
started wow dude
so your dad was a he was a kick boxing
trainer yeah yeah yeah so he started
from Q coach in karate okay so so yeah
and he got injured during a fight with
his leg and then yeah he needed to
recover so doing some fitness do some
boxing then started kickboxing then
people started asking hey why don't you
teach and he was like yeah let's go so
from that moment on he pulled me through
the gym and that's how it started was
done so you've been training since you
were six yes sir
wow man and you're 29 no 30 you're 30
what is your training regimen look like
outside of kickboxing acts outside of
your martial arts training are you doing
weights are you doing a lot of cardio
yeah yeah
so I think I I just started with
kickboxing kickboxing and weight
training and then I just look around at
the competition everybody was doing the
same but I think I was thinking like
hey I'm big and I'm heavy so naturally
I'm slow but I was always training with
like middle weight guys so I thought I
need to get faster I need to have more
energy to keep up with those guys so I
started trying and implementing
different trainings from different
sports into kickboxing like I was
thinking let's try this and do some more
explosive training so some more agility
the speed ladder stuff like that running
up the stairs and and that was working
and that now I think gives me a big
advantage on all the rest of the guys
hey yeah yeah and of course that and
just every time I'm never comfortable
with where I am so even now I'm still
looking at what can I do different or
what can i what can I do better
would you like the fireman time talk
about any organization who its champion
would you wanna fight um whatever
whatever would work you know I think
what out if I was if now we're talking
like a dream scenario yeah like how cool
would it be but you should have another
guy that would like that too to have a
mix fight so we had like corner go to
boxing yeah but how crazy would it be
for example and heavyweight ufg UFC
champion let's do an MMA fight and let's
do a kick boxing fight oh yeah or let's
do a boxing fight and let's do a
kickboxing fight for a boxing dude I
think that would be insane I think
that's the [ __ ] future dude I hope so
have you heard of the PFL yeah of course
that's dope yeah it's on Davis and his
and his buddy in here the other day hit
challenge anybody may not live any
champion against his champion Maidana
his champion the one that takes all yeah
shouldn't they do I think they should
put up a little bit more
[Music]
Michael pump it up might be the promoter
but more money of yeah yeah [ __ ]
coca-cola to throw money down david
alkyl throw down fifteen million already
talked to him about it yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude but don't you see i think that
would be a great idea you have all the
best from each league fight each other
yeah and but also then cross yeah and
cross over absolutely tell us about the
glory glory league glory
yeah glory kickboxing the big boxes yeah
so it's pure kick box it's pure chaos
yeah they have the best they are the
best stand-up combat check them out
you're right on the phone so they have
all the best kick boxers yeah yeah and
they're they're making the the biggest
fight the biggest fights so and of
course you have a lot of different
organizations as well now at the moment
but still they're not they're not on
that level it's like like everybody
wants to be here because they want to
compete with the very best
Rory's the top yeah it Louis the top so
you can be a kickboxer in the UFC right
or no yeah but I should definitely work
on my takedown defense since yeah stay
upstanding but it's a what you see in K
boxes just an MMA it's a totally
different sport the whole distance
changes the whole distance game changes
from so now actually to give you guys a
very very very exclusive thing we're
making the biggest fight the biggest
kick boxing fight there is its Rico
versus bar re so we did it once well
number one what happened
now
like don't forget to ship out those
hoodies hey what's up I'm not gonna get
the hoodies out in time man Evan I'm
busy okay and then photoshoot wait tight
ship station comm ship station right now
hot box and listeners can try ship
station free for 60 days when you use
promo code hot box them there's
absolutely no risk you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info so use code hotboxing
and get your ship together that ship
station dot-com
oh oh we got another champion coming in
amen so Bronco here in the building yeah
what a gold belt top ten knockouts of
all time and glory these guys these guys
aren't so when you fight kickboxing you
don't have anything on your shins or
don't feed the toad the same as MMA but
we're just not allowed to clinch or just
for a few seconds AHA and and that's it
this is the light heavyweight division
light heavies so we were just talking
about doing a cross league cross
discipline tournament to see who the
best fighters in the world are cross
league cross so like the best fighters
from the UFC fight the best fighters
from the PFL fight the best fighters
from glory now the thing is what would
be the rules exactly there you go these
are the these are the logistics we got
to figure out should do a mixed fight so
you fight a glory champion in your
division in kickboxing but also in
me okay well anyway you should go yeah
but then you'll get it you'll get a
bunch of one and one you'll get a bunch
of me go over there potentially get beat
up in a kickboxing fight and he come
over here and get smashed in MMA fight
or submitting yeah you'll get a bunch of
those I think I do actually think one of
C is doing something like that to where
they're mixing it to where it's like
kickboxing with MMA gloves yeah one more
time like that they're getting the
closest to it but I mean MMA is
self-explanatory is everything yeah as
every mix yeah how do you feel about
Rico going in there and working on your
ground game I did it you did you've done
that yeah I did one MMA fight oh really
yeah how'd it go how'd you feel yeah it
was fun
yeah it's different yeah but for damn
sure was a lot of fun yeah but it's just
yeah something you have to get used to
it's like the first time you get into an
octagon is like totally different than
getting into a ring you feel naked yeah
like I remember the feeling it was ah
you train the whole time and when you're
training people don't pay attention
you're training and training you got
shirt on you got you know shorts or
whatever pants or whatever you have on
baby shoes big boxing gloves and you
train then you're doing all that but
then I remember that moment I was
walking into the cage for the first time
my professional fight yeah and I didn't
have any amateur fights I went straight
pro and so I was climbing up on my gosh
I'm naked all I have is these little
tights on and these little 4-ounce glove
with wraps on I'm naked in here and it
wasn't until I even when I hit him for
the first time that was the first time I
actually like really hit somebody with
malicious intent like actually trying to
hurt them I'm like oh this is different
it's a different feeling and then once I
got hit it was a fight nah yeah let's do
it
Trevor bear what I remember is like in
the ring out in the end it's the same
but in the ring when I step into the
ring I mean of course I'm used to it but
you got like a feeling you can still get
out you can't get through it through the
ropes yeah when you get when I got into
the Octagon and I was in there my
opponent was in there and the door
closes like hey you're in a cage the
different it's a different mind-blowing
experience is it trip first of all is it
true from even be here
my you don't understand how many almost
fights you caused in my house growing up
I remember it was one fight I was at one
fight that we bought and my dad just had
these fight parties and so and now and
I'm Nigerian and so we all the you know
the Nigerian the friends you would call
them fmi like my dad's friends they
would all come over to watch the fights
and my dad ordered the fights so it's a
big night we got the beers got the
coolers got the drinks over there we had
food for everybody you know the manner
huddled up gonna watch this the women
are all on the side talking and do what
they do and the kids were kind of
playing but I always watched my dad I
always kind of was always focused on
what he was doing and my dad wanted to
run outside really quick for something
the fight was starting that they started
walking and you were walking I think one
time you you were walking in I could
remember you didn't even have a shirt on
you were walking in and boom you came in
and I was I was watching from a distance
and my dad ran I'm gonna run out real
quick come right back in he comes back
and fights over like I think you I think
it may be 30 20 seconds he took you
boom boom guys out my dad comes in
fights over and I don't remember exactly
but it was somebody's gonna fight in
this house today somebody gonna fight
my dad was so bad that so he got to
watch these two replays yeah and that
was my childhood gonna and and watch it
my and one thing that I also remember
that I said I would do is I don't know
if it was an interview of yours or you
said that the first belt you got was it
was a WBC no yeah and you said that you
like almost what you wore for almost
like a week what everywhere and and I
was like man if I ever win a belt I'm
gonna do that too yeah I'm gonna wear it
in the shower I'm gonna wear but I got
the belt I was like what should I do it
said I put it next to me when I sleep
out of it yeah yeah I got a friend here
that I in the world wears it it would
wear it everywhere carries all his belts
everywhere and I don't know did you guys
know he had to go model to beautiful he
will tell you guys he has a gold medal
as well let's go everywhere Zia Henry we
I was just with him you know yeah I was
just with him Henry yeah so who'd oh
he's been on it's been in here man
there's my guy Henry's the man man hit a
lot of champs on this pod now it's a lot
of gold and then I walk I'm like wow
there's a lot of gold in this building
ago the food thing get it yet your food
hungry my magnesia if I need a run and
go get food myself I'm gonna get food
yeah um famished
they can hear us out there whoever it is
only our bros absolute in a hog as fast
as possible
yeah dude they're on it they're on the
food baby but Mike attended glory yeah I
like glory bill tell us about it bro
listen man it was exciting I think those
will be like UFC but you know these guys
are getting knocked out cold you get
knocked out cold
I throw in this one guy oh thank you
gonna knock them out knock the guy out
that said what's up to you so you just
like turn your face like but that's
that's it Mike I don't know if you I
don't know people realize that protect
yourself at all times that's that
[Laughter]
[Music]
redhot champagne just carry these around
for you this is incredible stuff man
here come up here come up this way a
little bit first and we'll tell Nick
with the view of Henry say tell
everybody what's up brother
it's great to see you again it's great -
it's great to be with it was a gift you
know the first time I smoked with Uncle
Mike thank you brother I you know it's
hard it was hard for me to to do that
you know the reason why Mike I say that
is because a lot of people still have a
bad stigma because of this you know why
you think that isn't me what's the back
I mean fighting people people are still
caught up in 1950 to 1937 and anyways I
got I got you know a lot of people were
a lot of people gave me a lot of like do
you smoke with Mikey did all this and it
was fun Mike
they better get it right Mike is on the
focus game they better get it right I've
got the munchies on I said Mike was lit
before the podcast Uncle Mike forgot my
name I was like Mike oh I said you
tweeted me yeah you know what one thing
that I was I was people I don't know if
you understand it this is a rare thing
is that star power there's a moment
where you you have that star power to
where you I think you don't even realize
anymore how people see you how you
perceived and like Mike I don't know if
you know this but it doesn't matter if
it's it's Superbowl champions in the
room it doesn't matter if it's NBA
champions if it's NASCAR champions if
Tiger Woods is in the moon it doesn't
matter at what time they're whatever
they're doing if Mike Tyson walks in the
room everybody knows Mike Tyson's in a
room and that that I think that's the
level of star power that as athletes we
only dream up and I think that was the
same dude Muhammad Ali as well that's
something that people only know but
could I stop you there for a minute but
I'm gonna tell you this too and I want
to share story though Mike but I'm sure
you fill it a lot at the same time with
what you're saying - and you feel it now
you know you're a chap and I see you get
pulled around and but it's hard man this
man has no privacy man no how much can I
tell you guys a quick story real quick
it's a good story so everything that
you're saying loose Montauk for sure G
but what he has to deal with - ma'am my
god bless you
anyways I'm gonna tell you guys a quick
story because I kind of kind of want to
fall into this real quick I was I threw
out the first pitch for the Florida
Marlins and and the Derek Jeter I guess
he's an MMA fan you know this is Terry
this is Derek Jeter this is this is the
man and you know he wanted to meet me so
I throw out the first pitch for the
Florida Marlins and they told me they
said uh and around this time I had just
beat Demetrius Johnson so I had just
beat Demetrius Johnson I was in the
world when I had a lot of people you
know
a lot of a lot of people knew who I you
know who I was like I was big and I I
just didn't know how to handle it my cuz
there's a lot of people man a lot of
like my energy was being sucked like
literally like I was just sick of it and
then you know I go up and I so they told
us I had their did you Derek Jeter wants
to meet you and he's in a suite and like
one of the most prestigious persons like
in sports is up there and you know we
want to surprise you when you when you
go up to the suite I'm just like mouths
like you know I wonder who I wonder who
could it be you know I mean so one of
the best one of the greatest sports
figures of all time in the world period
so I'm just thinking okay whatever I
don't know man yeah I met I met Mike
Tyson I met I meant I meant I've done
that anyways I go up there I see Derek
Jeter and to my right I said Michael
Jordan was like right there like sitting
and peacefully watching the game and I
sit there I was talking to probably
Derek Jeter for like 20 minutes I'm more
their kind of stirring that Michael
Jordan because you know it's Michael
Jordan someone were there staring and
keep looking back like oh that's that's
a Mike and then finally I after 20
minutes Derek Jeter was like asses you
know I kinda I was gonna go back down
and watch a game like let him have his
his time with his family with this kid
and he's like Henry he's like do you
wanna you want a picture with Mike well
Jordan and I'm like I'm like I do Derek
but I know what this man goes through
and I just I just can't do that to him
he's watching the game he's like he's in
this position right here and then the
cool thing about is Derek Jeter looks at
me which [ __ ] mate he's like Henry he
says I like you man you're a [ __ ]
stud I like him would you show can and I
laugh you know what I mean so the moral
the story is is man the man needs his
piece the man easiest path as legendary
as he is and I don't think people
sometimes respect that people human be
care people don't care I think they have
just overwhelms them overwhelms and they
just think I want to picture I want to
touch him I want to do something to get
close to this person because they get so
excited yeah I mean of course we know it
what
the people Vanessa I really think they
purpose was when Jesus was around he was
like a rock star and its purpose was to
like the people feel them and touch him
let them know this and you could be
whatever you want to be to or whatever
the message is one they gave back in
those days the gladiator save I gave
their message you know I think that set
the tone know that set the tone if if
someone of that figure wants people to
touch and people to be around people to
you know to embrace him and then now
that trickles down for years and
centuries and decades now people feel
that same way about greatness
everybody's attracted to greatness
people want to be around someone who's
great that's doing something
in my life I met a lot of great people
all the great most of the great people I
met they want good people and ever since
then I decide I wanted to be more
acquainted with good people you know
because as the way the person lived his
life that's how he should be judged
mostly then I participated in a sport or
a politician or race campaign or
whatever because that's what we have to
give each other you know me who we are
as people
we can't everybody can't be the champion
but they can take that fame that will of
being a champion be a champion and
another physical you know it could be a
literature field to be any other field
is all about the will of the people
that's all that's all we got we all
spirit that's all the fighting spirits
some I could take that same spirit and
be another field and be successful
you're gonna I think that's what we we
are feeling now is like we're champions
we're on a level and we just decide if I
can speak for for myself I'll just love
to inspire people well in whatever way
possible just to give them because we
all had it we all had it before we had a
dream of becoming champion but everybody
can I have a dream in whatever in doing
whatever and just follow your dream and
you'll get there thank you yeah you guys
are all embodiments of greatness and
human potential you know and at the same
time you're human beings you have taken
your god-given abilities
whatever that is just as a human being
that we all have you know we all have
the potential to exert as much energy as
we want and put out as much energy as we
want and you know to me that's what
struck me when I first met Mike you've
come in thinking you're gonna meet
Hercules and you meet a man who's humble
and you see all of the humanity and you
realize wow we can all do this if we
have enough focus and discipline and
work
ethic and we put the right intention to
our attention to our intention we can
all achieve whatever our dreams whatever
our heart desires you know and you guys
are the full [ __ ] manifestations of
that in your own lives and you get to
project that to everyone and green
aye aye there's a saying that I I I
really firmly believe it is with great
power comes great responsibility
and I am an absolute firm believer in
that because now in the position that
I'm in I don't know about all of you
guys but I would I think grow up to
where I asked to where you know what
give me the power one day to be this
figure to where I get to motivate and
and everyone's watching what I do
I never necessarily asked for that I was
just put in I got put in that position
to where to I had to I had to own it I
had to realize oh you know what I am the
first African UFC champion ever and and
we don't I don't I never grew up
thinking oh yeah I'm gonna be the UFC
champion I never grew up thinking that I
just I got put in this position to where
now the continent of Africa get to look
at me and say oh crap there's another
guy that went through what I went
through having to walk a mile or miles
to get water bring it back so we can
boil the water to have water to eat to
cook to clean to live on for the day
ooh the guy that has to wash their
clothes and dry them outside wash their
hand wash clothes to dry them outside if
we wanted food you had to plan it have
it grow and harvested to eat so when we
had food for the season stuff to sell
like kids that are in that situation
right now that wake up not even it could
they can't fathom thought of knowing
that hey you know I'm gonna be on TV one
day I'm gonna be able to be doing
something greater as in being a world
champion so where I can touch and
motivate people motivate kids but now
I'm in that position so it's it's a
surreal experience to be able to be in
who's can I bring you back to
while you're saying I never dreamed of
being the first African UFC champion you
never dreamed of that no what did you
dream of what was in your mind's eye of
your visualization of your future when
you were beginning on this path as a
fighter or maybe it was before that I am
honestly I've actually it's an amazing
question I've actually thought about
that a lot and from day to day what I
can recall was I just I wanted to be
better than the day before and so when I
when I got into wrestling I didn't know
what I was doing like the first two
weeks this girl beat the [ __ ] out of me
through the practice and I kid you not
this girl terrorized me I still know her
name - in high school freshman year
Angela Martinez you know who you are yes
she was a three time state champion she
terrorized me like kept taking me down
just beating on me and um and what I can
recall was I used to walk home after
school and I would walk home and I'll be
thinking i'ma [ __ ] that girl up tomorrow
okay i'ma tomorrow I'm again and I'll
come back and she'd still kicked the
crap out of me and then I'll walk home
I'm okay I'm gonna get her I'm gonna get
her and she still kicked the crap out of
me and after a while after a while we
were gone and I don't know how long it
was maybe a month maybe two months I hid
a move on her and it worked and I just
remember that was progress in my mind I
kept coming I kept learning and I got
better and that was just a story of
everything you just be better than then
yesterday let's get better tomorrow
let's get better tomorrow let's learn
something new the way just progressed to
where so we used to say day by day and
every way I'm getting better better and
better
colder in the house yeah you know what
are you I'm high I'm high watching of a
beautiful I feel like I missed the beam
three fried rice and beans like super
clean these days and another step they
got the real food they got the biggest
[ __ ] in the world a guacamole with it in
the world if you put guacamole this [ __ ]
it be better
[Laughter]
do you guys also have that in during
training I was wondering because for me
it's the Mike Tyson move the right body
punch and the right uppercut and I got a
laugh so many times when I'm sparring
but not laughing out loud but just in my
head when they just they just throw it
they just throw the right body put and
you know the Mike Tyson move come
because they're gonna throw the right
uppercut it's like man I love it I knew
that was cold as the Mike Tyson would
have seen up means to move God remove I
learnt it from my trainer so what's
going on with the toad Mike I told this
beautiful man imma do it again sometime
this month but the toad is like nothing
else man you know yes and you never know
I did it around five time you never know
what you're gonna get I'm sayin now I'm
in better shape in better condition now
cuz the last time I did the toad the
toad I mustering over wake and I what
the toe told me to get in shape get in
better condition it's not gotten better
conditions I wanna see what's gonna
happen now and I take it yeah you know
what are the first time I was on your
show the first time I came on your show
remember we talked about it you told me
about the totem and I was a virgin kind
of it tripped me out a little bit but
then I started hearing like more and
more about it and I'm curious to try it
someday and it's like it's like you died
me god it's really bizarre hydrogen of
the attack that part of your brain we
someone of your experience that you've
done it you think you think this is the
right age to do the toad or do you think
a 32 year old could do it like myself
absolutely okay but you think uh in our
position right now it's the being in our
position is the right time to do it only
you can decide it's gonna tell you
they'll tell you now you're gonna do the
toes toes gonna take everything you
don't want gonna blow your [ __ ] mind
you think you've seen it all you think
listen I'm not I'm not frightened of a
lot of things but but this year I think
the fear of the unknown of what's inside
my mind is that's probably one of my
biggest fears because I'm uh I
internalized a lot of things if you ever
in your life you know I know who I feels
are all champions and stuff but you see
ever in your life think that you're
something especially in your big and
you're like I'm a garli figure you take
the total that's gonna let you know that
whoa you're nothing and nothing yeah Wow
you start praying you realize your any
purpose here to worship something you're
not gonna know what it is but it's like
a god secret to us I guess that's our
only purpose to be humbled Wow yeah
that's not necessarily uh it's not
necessarily a bad thing man this is why
you probably do too you probably miss
your heart and then we clean you take
the Tovar everything you think you know
everything you think you know your hell
does a secret boom everyone knows now
everyone knows like you think everybody
knows
[Laughter]
everybody knows all your secret
everything you think you'd be the
holding if he knew that about me if they
knew this about yeah now you got the
feeling that anybody knows that man holy
[ __ ] what's gonna happen now yeah no
about you boo I think we need a start
that's the toad retreat my mango the
toad retreat I want to do any
reservation do you think what I mean
Mike looking where you're right now do
you think something like that could
drastically change where I might you
know what I don't want to fight anymore
baby I know nobody might tell you man it
may tell you so many may give you a
purpose to fight yeah I never knew you
might it might further right you might
be fighting the build River dams in
Africa somewhere Haiti you think you
know something you take the toe you
don't know [ __ ] I've been all over the
world burn all kind of woman did all
kind of drugs doing all kind of looking
through all kind of people fans with
every position royally you take the top
whoa I don't know [ __ ] I'm a dumb
[ __ ] I don't know [ __ ] my whole
life was a waste
wow that's and uh you see you've met
Rashad Evans yeah Rashad is uh Rashad is
my big brother and I say that because uh
and like missus what they've gone back
to what we were talking about with great
power comes great responsibility I think
he said that when he was on here yeah
it's a certain same thing Rashad was one
of those guys who he was in a position
to where he had the power he was a
superstar he was at the top of the sport
and he was the first time ever and and
that I've ever been starstruck was with
Rashad and I met him in in Denver he
walked into a gym when I came in the
Train
and uh and I turn around and I saw him
oh [ __ ] that's what shot I was still
saying I could I could be could be
coming on saving and we worked out that
session together and after we worked out
and Here I am I'm just a guy wrestler
training for the Olympics and this is a
superstar known worldwide and we sat
down and we just talked and he was I Big
Brother we just we just talked I didn't
have those those restrictions those fear
of know what to say what not to say and
he didn't as well and I just couldn't
believe of a guy of his stature that
Superstar was able to do that and just
be so bare so wrong with you know he
doesn't code as well yes he's charging
and he realized Oh purple I have to do
it until you realize I'll put we're here
for a reason we think we don't know why
we just action so what's your purpose
your name [ __ ] you know so we're here
for reading all we're all [ __ ] here
this is our purpose to be a thumper to
educate one enough to teach us just to
teach us that and we're just here we
think we're [ __ ] I'm pretty much
steering our own life and putting
ourselves in that position but we're not
yeah there's no nothing coincidental we
can't just describe it you know sometime
you think about some of you haven't seen
them must like they know they call you
and you can't explain that yeah man if
you have that happen every time you want
to talk to somebody think about them and
they call you you probably did that one
time we have son wanna make it work when
that but we just trust me it's a greater
force and not us well on that mic and
tying that back to your thing no no no
exactly what you're saying
of you're thinking about somebody and
then they call you or many of these
instances happen throughout our lives
that if we're in tune enough we can pick
them up and recognize them but like that
experience of the toad and all your
secrets are out there for the world to
see and feel you know at the end of the
when they look under a microscope at
everything it's all just energy and
vibration and so we're all just mad you
know we're all we're not even matter
we're energy waves
we're particles you know why we get mad
when we mad and
yeah you know just we got this [ __ ]
building on top of that our thoughts
every thought that we have is a
vibration that sends out like we're just
antennas of energy and vibrations that
just go out into the universe and if
people are in touch enough you can just
you can pull them out of thin air
basically you know so yeah to quell that
fear of yours is that so many people are
turned off that they're not aware enough
to pick up on anything anyway you know
and with technology and all of the 5g
waves that were being blasted with and
all the cell towers and everything else
that's going on the radiation
you know these this sensitivity that
human beings are naturally gifted with
since you know for hundreds of thousands
of years since we came into being
whatever that was this is an ability
that we have that's just been dulled
over the centuries to what it is now
where many people are just driving
around asleep at the wheel I just went
on a tangent
Henry's a little stung dr. strange [ __ ]
Mike you got you got you got a watch it
it's it's kind of tying into this yeah
that fear because he goes into after
he's a medical doctor and then he
crushes his hands yeah and then he goes
seeking for searching for purpose I I'm
guessing yeah and actually he would he
actually was searching for being selfish
wanted to get his hands back so he can
go back to operating that was his life
this one's like a master neurosurgeon a
rockstar yeah but then he gets over to
where was it somewhere in Nepal or so
someone Yoshi
and he finds this the lady who temple oh
yeah yeah and they just kind of pull him
into this and it just the way that they
that she they work the energies that
mentions it different very told and this
is what scares me is if there's really
energy out there like if there's really
a power like
yeah and that that right there is mind
blowing yeah but don't you have to feel
like the feeling I have it's like I give
a lot of presentations and I'm telling
the story and then at a certain point
there comes a picture and where you see
me sitting after the first time I became
champion to build like this and I always
say say after this picture was made I
could have dropped dead and it wouldn't
have mattered because I've done what
I've been put on this earth for it to do
and that was becoming kick boxing world
champion because that was my my sister
platform was like man that that's my
vision of of how I approach things is
like there's this I'm walking on a path
but the path is already he's already
there you know it's already I'm walking
it but it's it's already certain what's
gonna happen where are you gonna go next
prime minister yeah yeah you don't know
on the toad the experience that when you
have the toad what it feels like but
don't you feel like the adversity that
you've lived here on earth has kind of
given you that purpose right you know
what I mean like it's almost like you've
gone through a lot Mike and you've
learned through a lot you you've fallen
you have gotten up you don't think I
mean what other than than that could you
say that the total gives you right don't
we all recognize our flaws that we all
recognize just like all of us we all had
our tests God gives us our tests they
really show how strong we really are
tests that we don't even know maybe
losing our parents at a young age maybe
losing somebody that affected our family
there's something that's my little shits
whatever it may have been some a
affected us it may be a [ __ ] this for
me a matter of years you know and that's
what it really comes to going overcoming
adversity in life you know some people
get shot no people get shot at it's what
happened when you deal with that
adversity what are you gonna do you let
your lay down for you or keep
fighting it and that's what life's about
fighting adversity and overcoming
adversity and seeing what kind of person
you'll be bitter and mean because life
isn't kind to you oh you figured it
wasn't kind to you are you gonna say
[ __ ] then live life to its fullest means
and be chappie I you know it's like a
slap good I let I am I'm blessed
cuz I think at all time I'm blessed to
ha just how many people I'm connected to
in some way shape form or fashion how
just that the connections that I've have
in this world and I just know it I it's
something bigger that I that that's a
store for me to do because like I'm
connected to this guy this guy's you
were born in where Netherlands I was
born in will be on in Nigeria I'm a
village I come little boy but look where
I'm at I'm connected to this guy because
I ran into him I've known him for years
yeah ran into him for years I'm
connected to this guy what what were you
born having me California California
just an Olympic champion two-time board
two division world champion yeah I was
connected to this guy have known him for
years
yeah do this journey of life I'm
connected to you my god the girl I grew
up watching you I grew up learning and
hearing and seeing about you to where
like this connection do you think this
is all because of your hard work no no
and that's that's the purpose that's my
fear the divine putting us in the proper
perspective and we're all here for a
reason we don't know the reason but
we're here for everything maybe we're
supposed to decipher that this is my
back you know our life was just a big
surprise but it was spectacular he and
Mandy was definitely gonna be like the
magic God made all this beautiful stuff
made us to feel this way and it's gonna
black it out and get rid of it do you
think that's really gonna happen the
energy that we feel that we have when we
talk when we thinking right now thinking
you think this it's gonna get cold
blanket or exists no more once with this
body's dead I don't know but do you
think that that's gonna be over that
energy that we have right now let's make
you think they're making over think
right now you think that's gonna die
that's just gonna be over when the body
dies I don't know I just can't imagine
that the toad didn't the toe didn't uh
you never that did you think of
afterlife with the toad when you had the
toad well when I listen when you take
the dog the toad is the closest thing to
death don't dad know about this and I
was comfortable with that that was
pretty awesome yeah awesome I'm just I
enjoy I enjoy asking Mike more questions
and I don't think we're all afraid of
death for death ISM death has to be
glorious
I can definitely live life not gonna be
bad
this would have to be just as good as
life cuz they're both spectacular
I want to do something because you guys
you guys here might talk dude I want to
hear more of them do you guys have
retired into that tying into what you
were just saying let's give I have a
deep question I turn into what you were
saying is why is it that when people
pass and I and I do this and I've done
this a lot because I am I I do have
faith and when someone passes of someone
that I know like their mom passes and I
always tell them and just to console
them and I let them know like hey don't
cry or don't don't be sad they're in a
better place they don't hurt any more
they don't feel the pain that we feel
here anymore they've passed on to a
better place but deep down inside I've
always questioned do I really feel that
do I really believe that because what's
gonna happen when I'm put in that place
in that situation and you told me that
you know obviously you you're doing the
toad has been the closest that you felt
to that like how and you've lost you've
experienced loss how is that different
now then years and years ago before
you've done the toad well no I don't
know what I believed before I did the
toad and most of the things I believe
before the toad I really didn't believe
and then once I did the tote I know
there's a possibility that there's
something greater than myself it has to
because I realized that I'm not nothing
you know because I can't save someone I
love from denying the great that's just
the creative that the grid is what
someway I love them care about the Stein
I can't save them you know so I realized
this has to be something bigger and I
want to believe from after user told one
side one side I I'll be able to see them
and gonna meet them again but that
wasn't a reality when I took the tour
when I took the toad was just all about
me everything I ever loved thought about
and ever cared about was not even in my
mind I never thought about it and none
existed so I never saw no happy face and
never got reacquainted with any
ancestors or people that were dead that
I loved it was just all about dealing
with me and whatever I had to deal with
within myself I don't think God deals
with a feather group like we do in
church or mosque for anything I think
it's the one-on-one deal I have to do
that oh yeah thing is one-on-one
do you think this doing the doing the
thought made you are you a better person
or a different person or your
perspective on yourself it made me
totally self conscious of myself you
know me my past laws and stuff yeah so
for those the things I had to make to
reach the level that I am now yeah you
know everything's make makes more sense
yeah everything for a lotta sense now
and I was up to me to make this continue
on this Riley to [ __ ] it up you know
I think we got to start a new show thank
you talking the people talking about
afterlife yeah I get some of those
people in this show yeah Sadhguru else
Tony's didn't do it that's someone those
stuff you know they're thinking about as
we get older so yeah gotta stay bad to
get old that they get older I wonder
like wow I won't be in another 50 years
what's the hell's gonna go on what's
happening
remember those other fighters before me
how do they think I'm thinking himself
not being in this world I couldn't think
of this world without them being in
there well can we be you know could we
be in so long so how can we think of
being anywhere else let's get the
reprogram I mind the deal what we're
gonna go after we leave here yeah I I
want to ask this because this is
something that I frequently battle with
in my mind is is we feel that there was
a time where I as a kid I remember when
I was like sixth grade and I was just
always like man I can't wait to be 18
cuz now I get to buy cigarette I get to
buy cigarettes I can't wait to be 21 I
didn't even care about alcohol but it
was I get to do that I get to buy
alcohol so I just remember the feeling
of feeling like a kid always felt like a
kid and then a teen came and went
twenty-one came when and now I know that
there's certain things that I can't do
is like as yourself Mike are you able to
look outside yourself and it may be be a
little envious or a little jealous of
yourself that because I hear some guys
you know former athletes champions look
at themselves now I'm like man cuz
they're older and then they're like man
you know how tight I was at twenty-one
you know how how tight I was and I'm 32
now I don't feel I don't see that I
still feel like a kid it's good you know
like in my head I still feel like a kid
I didn't know I don't know I didn't
notice that I'm no longer 12 anymore I
know I'm not 18 I'm not 21 not 24 I'm 32
I didn't I don't feel that time
do you ever my outside kind of like look
into your body and just be like man
envious of I was 22
you know I look at myself in sin while
these kids are smart kids and stuff I
couldn't handle all that energy other
stuff I had it was explosive tearing me
apart had to be involved with something
yeah Mike the the feeling you have now
the person you are today what would that
person tell Mike Tyson the young Mike
Tyson what would he tell them then how
would he advised him to to what's coming
even though the dista stood the path
would be the same do you take the young
Mike Tyson would take it and listen well
I was telling me listen whatever you do
get stopped on the starting now and he
might have mercy saying you get on your
knees
start praying do you think the young
Mike Tyson will listen no way
so wouldn't have made it you're gonna
listen listen eventually guess that's
why they say you live in you learn right
that's why I think like I said you know
there's there's a path and we just walk
in the path but the paths already there
yeah everything happens on that path we
meet people that's why I always say hey
I try to surround myself with people
with positive energy and everywhere like
we were talking about everybody gives
out a certain type of energy and certain
energy you just feel you're on the same
level and some energy does this doesn't
work you're not loving anything greater
than yourself you ain't livin ain't
livin that's about getting to know
yourself and if you live for whatever
length of life you live in don't get to
know yourself it's a wasted life so you
think you know yourself the best now
than that I've ever known before this
stage of my life here this is how deep
what I like it
we got to do this man young fighters
young champions being with Mike they
don't understand they they capable of
doing whatever they want you know of
course nothing fighting like a spirit
and stuff and it's not necessarily the
style of fighting but the morality
behind the style remember the
determination the willpower
that I mean the dedication to give me a
total life to this whole science of
fighting and stuff like that and stuff
and it's very special it's been
specially since the beginning of time
since the first two people ever did it
and it's not gonna ever go away if
anything that they make more hearts of
fighting you know this is the oldest
this is probably one the first things
any humans ever did was fight you know I
don't care who you are where you are
it's like you're you're in a room and
there's a lion like sitting in the
corner and you come in and you yeah
that's the presents that I feel like I'm
in there's lions like there's there's a
there's big big majestic animals like it
just beans in the corner and it doesn't
matter what's going on I get drawn here
there's all this this energy it just I
feel it I used to say to my trainer I
just read about old faster car how could
anybody beat him he has losses on the
ring he was an animal I could anybody
beat them in the my trainer come on sir
there's some people I can handle animals
you know and then that was that's true
you know me interesting there's certain
people they may not be flashy fighters
or they may not be charismatic funny
because while I was great but for some
reason they always beat the badasses
yeah
handle those kind of guys like handle
those badasses yeah it's more very basic
fight at the basic technique please know
all the rules tool T experience Friday
that happens in team sports as well like
in the NFL certain teams know how to
play against the Patriots and always
kick their ass all the Patriots are just
kicking everybody's ass chip will see
over here in the corner triple sir how
are you feeling Manning back in ancient
time when they had the the punic was
back there and everything like Kili very
good my fighter challenged your fighter
want to control the whole country now
you don't come back you in [ __ ] Troy
yeah Brad yeah he's like chillin in the
tent with the two chicks and they're
like Achilles man you gotta go grabs his
sword and walks out there yeah now what
prey what kind of pressure what did you
think
Achilles felt the pressure that he felt
crazy there's no beat me I'm a goddamn
team to match me yeah that's kind of
what the movie portrayed it that's what
I got from that yeah it's supreme
confidence you know people even someone
got entertainers fighters too sometimes
their confidence in their ego you know
it blurs the line the [ __ ] delusional
manga Romania madman [ __ ] insanity
yeah but is that my is that the
mentality that we have to have at the
time yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I say I didn't I was I was
skeptical about about saying this
because this is one thing that I do
Thursday when I when I walk towards that
cage is and I it was things that I used
to do before competing all through
wrestling but once I started fighting
and I and I my mind went to the point
where I started thinking of myself in
that way to become champion oh yeah I
watch I watched you're on this PETA the
documentary and when you broke down your
walk and I started thinking that I do I
do that now it's when I walk out there
I'm dancing but I'm dancing because that
walk I know it's nervous and that what
it takes me dance and that's the most
one of the biggest best things that I do
that it takes me away from nervousness
everything so I dance but while I'm
dancing I'm talking to myself and I get
closer and I do that is one thing that I
do say to myself is supreme confidence
no one can beat me in there no I have to
always have the supreme confidence you
know some good some of these dumb what
would be he was like a Persian general
was it who was he Xerxes one thing he's
in a battle something's not going wrong
every time he loses what he can't
imagine the next time he loses only
reason I lose because God is jealous
because I'm getting so close to him do
you notice cause he never mess you know
he never he never mess with the answer
the bugs always strike he always strike
the biggest tree or the biggest animal
he's getting just I'm getting close to
his lovely perch I got a dare lose it's
only because of Carly's jealousy and I
lose they go that level are you guys
good to go
you got it yeah I just have to run to
the bathroom
[Laughter]
hey what fight did you walk into most
confidently some food for thought
yes Henry you want to meet you
attack that confident that fight you
guys give me this mic you like it she
come you guys feeding me the mic we want
I would have here I want to hear fight
we'll fight was it or fight what fight
what do you mean what fight from like
that you and my confident okay yeah I'd
have to say the I have to say what TJ
Dillashaw oh man I was very very
confident on that fight just a simple
fact that I I've always I've always had
a desire to fight him and uh you know
he's easily he's a great fighter man
he's a great fighter I think that's what
kind of drove me a maybe more confident
because I knew was gonna bring the best
out of me it's fighting like a high
level fighter like that but I felt
confident because of it it took me to a
whole nother level of mindset yeah and
that was that was against aus against
against TJ even though he was probably
the better of the other of them all yeah
for me I would say it was a guy for
Sergio Mariah's and he it was kind of a
brawler but he was uh or also one of
like the most decorated jujitsu guys in
the sport
I mean his victories over Krong Green
seems like the last guys like be like
he's you just saw it three times Jitsu
world champion or something like that
but I mean I knew he had holes and the
reason I was confident in this fight was
because I trained differently because
this guy was offered to me a couple
fights ago and I turned the fight down I
said no I didn't want to fight that
fight because I didn't really I thought
that I was better than then that guy
because they they had promised me
something before it didn't work out but
as I said I turned the fight down and
then I got a I got in trouble I got an
extended my contract and then the fight
came up again to three fights later and
I just remember I trained so differently
for that fight because I had a chip on
my shoulder I was like I'm gonna prove
to them there's a reason they tried to
give me this guy twice because I think
they feel that this guy could derail me
he could take me down or submit me or
knock me out or something and I just
remember I I trained and my whole the
training camp my mind was somewhere
different to whatever when I walked in
there I just I watched the fight and I I
watched myself and I try to put myself
in the prêt that presidents of that
feeling the feelings that I had at that
moment and I just remember I was just
confident I that was the first time I
said you know what I'm gonna hit you and
you're gonna go to sleep I don't care
what happens but I know my hands hurt
worse I'm gonna hurt you worse than your
hands gonna hurt my hurt me and that and
I ended up getting a knockout in that
fight I think for me was with the the
Badr Hari fight because it was I was
kickboxing champion for for some years
then but I fought everybody but I didn't
fight that guy and he was from the last
k1 days he was the man Rico fought and
beat everybody but he needs to fight
this guy to be really legit so I
remember that was the biggest kickboxing
fight there was at that moment and it
still is and it's coming again
so I remember coming into the arena
everybody went like crazy and I just
felt like this is this is my moment
after and then again like I said this is
this is my vision but I've been walking
on this path and this path has been
prepping me for this moment right here
and that's that's how confident I was
stepping in the ring and the first round
I just kept pressuring and he opened up
my nose and I wasn't even bothered I
wasn't even bothered I was focused I was
like this guy left or right doesn't
matter he's gonna give up he's gonna
break somewhere and he did so and now
this December we're gonna do that fight
once more so I can't wait so what was
your also brother I must have been tired
Oh big it was
Olympic champions the world amateur
champion and I was kind of jealous of
them cuz I was buckling the amateur date
he was getting all the person everyday
and so with time to fight I was champion
I was defending my title against them
and I was just at my best I was just
focused I was just I was just so relaxed
so common it's almost like that I
transcended that my my mind my spirit
left my body and I was watching myself
fight him you know it's weird and I was
just a great fight went seven rounds and
I think I looked my best now I want to
just tag onto that is which fight would
you say you had the purest and the
cleanest preparation for I don't know I
always stayed trained thank you I was
general nervous I have 15 fights in one
year it's always stayed active yeah give
him 15 15 yeah you know what you got
your to belt from two different weight
divisions right yeah the simultaneous
good and lose five pounds get the fight
again you get I will put ten more pounds
on together to fight the next guy that's
almost like unheard of nobody's ever
tell somebody to do something like that
yeah yeah but that's what we do that's
what comes with success man that's what
kind of wanted to bounce to we got
people I tell my working I was around 40
you know you gotta use a different
mindset you have to go was like an
animal you have to sacrifice so much you
know most like starve yourself yeah I
would just curiosity what weight
division do you feel most comfortable
because for me I prefer a boy I prefer
yeah yeah it's a lot better than I'm
gonna cut my balls off
yeah I mean that's pretty simple too I
mean it's pretty simple to answer but if
you also heard another division
I don't know but for me what works is
like I'm a heavyweight but I always drop
a little bit before if I get on a diet
and that that makes me feel better but
not better in the way of I feel stronger
or something but better in a sharpness
you know it gets me sharper because it's
another thing I'm adding 2 to n for me
my head as an advantage to to my
opponent like hey I'm focused and this
gets me even more focused but I don't
know if that if that works for you
because you guys have to go really deep
I don't have to go deep I just do it for
for me for the focus Alliser you want to
get that you want to get there no you're
right because I have I have moved up
away I have I wrestled at 165 and then
when I was in college I went up to 74
yeah it's a at some point yeah it you do
feel when you're not cutting away a lot
of people that they feel that instant
gratification so joy they're like oh
yeah one less thing whatever I could eat
now so it takes the focus away from the
goal which is normally to diet make sure
my diet at some point because in order
for me to compete at my best I have to
make the weight you know for me to even
compete I need to make the way so I
gotta make sure everything's in points
so that focus now you take that out some
people get lost
yeah some people get lost with it but I
completely agree with you and that's
something that that Francis in Gandhi
was doing now a little bit too he's he's
more caught when he fought for the title
he was just like he just wanted to be
big he said he just wanted to be big and
just want to be the biggest guy in there
but it cost him after a fight he said he
felt that he was too big he was too slow
too sluggish so now he he's cautious
tough around one weight he goes into the
fight and because he feels sharper and
feels strong and just just quicker and
smarter in there and I completely agree
with that
you know all the ancient gladiators they
check their bones and when they died no
and the scientists and the most of them
look like vegans and vegetarians they
didn't eat much meat if any really yeah
interesting Wow very interesting so Mike
you're gonna turn me into a vegan now is
not natural that's what we get all this
cancer all these [ __ ] gout
mike is really you know milk is like you
know cow myths is like you know pus yeah
yeah it's mucus Mike has slowly but
surely been convincing me that I need to
be a at least a vegetarian yeah I don't
do dairy
I don't do dairy but Mike do you think
it's there I know but do you think it's
do you think it's it's meat or do you
think it's the chemicals in the meal I
think if the chemicals in the me and I
don't think I think that meat is really
bad to eat as well thank you all would
you eat okay you know okay it's a
transfer rule of energy yeah but and
what okay so how is the animals so the
way that animal foods are processed and
you know creative is first of all they
have to kill these animals right and how
do you do that on an industrial scale
the easiest way possible and it's done
horrible it's it's disgusting you know
the way they treat the animals and so
you know animals if you're like me you
believe that animals are conscious
beings are just like us they feel
emotions and feelings and you know the
truth is is that when these animals are
being killed all of those fear hormones
are just flooding their system and it's
going into their tissues that we then
eat and consume and you're you know
you're taking on that energy first of
all and second of all you know spirit
physically I mean I think that there's a
lot to be said about consuming as many
plant-based foods as you can you know
from a health perspective and a
spiritual and moral perspective as well
you know I've always been a guy I've
eaten a shitload of meat yeah you know
and taught being with Mike is started to
shift that you know I'm eating much less
redness he's still young imagine at my
age you tighten it you can't [ __ ] right
I got the [ __ ] yeah that's it's much
yeah shits are much better when you eat
more veggies you know is it why is it
that my past with Mike when you guys are
talking about taking a good [ __ ] better
than a good hump a good take a good [ __ ]
and get your dick hard can you repeat
that take a [ __ ] yeah taking a good [ __ ]
taking a good dump is better than a good
hump passed away in the [ __ ] [ __ ]
Elvis really fun really that you start
yeah that's true hey thank you guys so
much this has been a blast yard
everybody thank you so much for watching
and listening until next time I'm out of
here one piece
[Music]